- Holistic and specialized
care for children with
Down syndrome at Children's
Hospital Oakland,
also known as BCHO.
And Renee Howard, who will be joining her
and following her talking about
skin problems with Down syndrome.
So welcome Doctor Spinazzi.
(applause)
- Good morning.
I will be your energy
producer this morning.
I think it's fitting that I get to talk
about Down syndrome as the
first talk of the morning.
Yesterday we started
with war and I always say
that if we all had Down
syndrome I doubt we'd have wars
in our world.
So we'll be switching gears a little bit.
I have nothing to disclose
other than my incredible
passion for this topic that you should
hopefully feel throughout this talk.
We have a few learning objectives.
I'd like to start by just
discussing why we should
have specialized clinic when it comes to
children with complex healthcare needs.
And then I'd like to tell you what we do
at our specialized Down syndrome clinic.
And then I'd like to focus on a few issues
that we've taken up at Charlie's Clinic
as specialized projects
that I think warrant
more attention that
they're currently given.
And that's the same
thing in different words.
So a study in 2014 by
Cohen & al. showed that
in the United States 5% of patients are
responsible for half of
our healthcare costs.
And they described six
different subpopulation
of patients who drive this high need,
and one of them is children
with complex needs,
which is described as a severe
impairment in at least four categories
including learning and mental functions,
communication, motor
skills, and self care,
as well as need in at least
two categories in terms of
enteral or parenteral
feeding, ventilatory support,
really the need for more
than a couple subspecialists
that are involved long
term in the child's care.
When I went to a talk on
complex healthcare needs
given by Doctor Antonelli from Boston,
I think he's at MGH or Boston Children's,
he showed this healthcare map.
And this feels so overwhelming and it is.
And it is an example of the healthcare map
for a child with complex healthcare needs,
and it shows how there's certainly
the doctor and the doctors,
so subspecialists,
as well as therapists,
as well as school,
as well as other potential involvement.
Social work related, legal
related, financial related.
And one can see how
completely overwhelming
and largely confusing this can feel,
especially to a family that
doesn't have prior experience
in taking care of a child
with complex healthcare needs,
which is the majority of families.
So this is a study from Figueroa & al.,
also published recently it's from 2018,
that discussed features of successful
care models in high-needs patients.
And it highlights four areas,
focus on service settings,
tailoring the service to a specific
population with a set of needs,
care model attributes
specifically matching
the needs of the child with practices that
understand the full spectrum
of the patient needs.
Care delivery features
which include extensive
outreach mechanisms to
patient's communities and home.
And an overall organizational
cultures that can
adapt and customize care based on the
changing needs of the patient.
And at Charlie's Clinic we take these
four core principles to heart.
So how does this apply to
individuals with Down syndrome?
There's approximately 250,000 individuals
with Down syndrome in the United States
as of this latest study from 2012.
And as many of us know they're predisposed
to a number of medical conditions.
And thankfully over the years that both
the American Academy of Pediatrics
and the Down Syndrome
Medical Interest Group
have put their heads together to develop
healthcare guidelines that can help us
tailor our care to the individual needs
and commonly occurring conditions
for individuals with Down syndrome.
However, even with these
beautiful documents
that tell us exactly what to do,
there are a lot of challenges for
all primary care doctors to coordinate
this comprehensive medical care.
Starting with, let's be
real, the 15 minute visit.
It's just not possible
to address all medical
and developmental concerns,
it's a huge topic.
Belief that we can do it and do it well.
There's evolving knowledge
and recommendations.
I subscribe on Google alert to articles
that come out on Down syndrome
and I get an email everyday with about
10 articles that have to
do with Down syndrome,
and not all of them are
clinically relevant to me,
but that's still a lot of
knowledge to keep up with
for just one of a myriad
of genetic conditions
that we heard all about
yesterday from Doctor Curry.
And then most pediatricians
have only a couple of patients
with Down syndrome so
there's limited comparison,
and if medicine is all
about pattern recognition
and recognizing what
deviates from the patterns,
that if your N is small then it's gonna be
harder to notice those differences.
I spoke about the guidelines,
so these are freely available online,
they're published by the
American Academy of Pediatrics
about every 10 years,
and it's a summary of
best practice guidelines.
This talk is about Charlie's
Clinic and yet I feel that you
should all know about these guidelines,
I won't be spending any
time talking about them
however I put a summary of the guidelines
at the end of this talk and
they're on your syllabus.
And these guidelines are
updated about every 10 years
and the groups are meeting starting DSMIC
this year in June to
update these guidelines.
Doctor Marilyn Bull is the most prominent
doctor is known for these guidelines,
but there's many others
that are contributing.
So this was a study by Brian
Skotko and his team at MGH,
speaking of big researchers
in Down syndrome,
follow Doctor Brian Skotko if you
like kids with Down syndrome,
he is driving the research and
the knowledge in this field.
And they looked at their
patients coming into
this big Down syndrome clinic at MGH
and what they saw is
that coming in only 16.7%
of patients were actually
up to date with guidelines.
And again this is no
fault of their doctors,
this is incredibly
overwhelming to keep up with.
And then if you look at DSMIC guidelines,
which are a little bit more
intense than the AAP guidelines,
only 9.8% were meeting
those guidelines as well.
Another study by Ferguson &
al. in Oklahoma and Nebraska,
less than 15% of individuals were found
to be up to date on thyroid
screening guidelines,
and this is huge because the
incidence of thyroid problems
in individuals with Down
syndrome is really high,
and especially in children,
especially in young children,
missing hypothyroidism is huge.
I have a patient that I now follow
who was transferred from another clinic
and when I met her, her TSH was 400,
and it's been gone unrecognized
for a really long time
and it was probably causing her headaches,
and she poked her eyes so
much that she's now blind.
And she has cretinism too and
this is something that was
completely preventable had
it only been recognized.
A study from Jensen et al.
less than 50% of adults
followed at U Michigan were
evaluated for sleep apnea,
atlantoaxial instability,
hearing loss and vision loss,
all important healthcare conditions to
keep in mind in individuals
with Down syndrome.
So what I'm trying to point out is
there's a need for Down syndrome clinics,
and I hope I'm starting
to convince you of this.
So cue in Doctor Bert Lubin, my hero,
also Santa,
and Doctor Lubin has a
son with Down syndrome
and I can tell you that
'cause he'll tell you that.
And his dream for his whole career was to
have a Down syndrome clinic
at Children's Oakland
and here comes this loud, boisterous,
young, young, young, young,
out of residency doctor
who doesn't know anything
but wants to do something,
and he provided the angel
funding to get this started
and the ongoing moral support as well as
academic guidance to make this happen.
So what is Charlie's Clinic?
Charlie's Clinic is a
multidisciplinary effort.
I am the physician for
Down syndrome clinic.
In the audience today is Marybeth Finch
who's our infant development specialist,
her time is covered by a grant,
and I cannot say enough
about what an incredible
thought partner and
teacher she's been to me,
so thank her if you see her today.
Leticia Gomez has just joined us,
she's our social worker also
covered through a grant,
she's bilingual and she's
starting to help us a lot
with what are the incredible
social needs of our families.
And then, and this is
what I'm most proud of,
Annika Miller who's our intern
and she has Down syndrome
and I'll talk a little bit more about her,
as well as Chanel Brisbane,
her Best Buddies job coach.
What do we do at Charlie's Clinic?
We do a lot.
We provide a comprehensive review of each
child's physical and mental health.
We compare what has been
done with the AAP guidelines
and provide recommendations
on how to catch up.
And we potentially identify
and recognize conditions,
and I would say that that happens
in the majority of visits,
it's rare for us to say
you're doing a great job, keep it up,
without having any homework to give
to families and the providers.
We focus a lot on development
with a giant focus on
independence with
activities of daily living.
Unlike other clinics we
don't yet have the formal
PT evaluation, OT evaluation,
speech evaluation,
and certainly that's a
dream to have those formal
evaluations but I think
that there's also an
advantage to having this
be more of a conversation,
because it gives us a chance
to give advice in the moment
and give feedback in the moment
about where the child is.
I steer away from any
table that tells families
when their child is supposed
to sit or crawl or stand,
'cause the truth is
development is individual
and I focus more on the quality
of the milestones rather
than the timing of it.
We talk a whole bunch about independence
because independent children
are independent adults
who work and live independently hopefully.
We provide developmental resources,
be it handouts, apps, websites,
guidance on how to create
visual task analysis.
We often, almost all the time,
reach out to regional
center case managers,
schools and other providers who are
interacting with our families.
We screen for a dual diagnosis
of Down syndrome and autism
and I'll spend a few slides
talking about why that's important.
We talk about behavioral
concerns, if there are any,
and give guidance to families about
how to address them and when appropriate,
refer for more intensive
behavioral support.
Often times we also broach the
conversation of medication,
which for some families has
already been on their minds
and for other families it is a really
new conversation to grapple with.
Whenever possible we look at
the IEP and whenever possible,
and I get real excited up when I get them,
we look at the triennials because there's
so much data and information out there
about our children and what's missing
is someone looking at all of it together
to get this whole child
picture of what's going on.
And then we do a lot of community building
and including warm handoffs
to other providers,
we put on a lot of trainings
and I'll talk about that,
and we create community.
So we've been around for
two and a half years,
but we've already given
a lot of trainings,
and I just put them all up here
to just show the
diversity of the training,
so some of them have been
grand rounds at our hospital,
some have been medical student lectures,
some of them have been lectures
to residents in family medicine practices
or other pediatric
practices around the area.
Some of them have been community trainings
available to not just
doctors but also nurses,
nurse practitioners,
social workers, therapists.
And then parent trainings as
well through our local Down
syndrome support organizations
as well as help us.
So we're trying to get the information
out in as diverse ways as possible.
So far we've done trainings
on supporting communication
in children with Down syndrome,
talking about puberty,
I'll be giving a talk
on puberty in Spanish
in June at the National
Down Syndrome Congress,
wish me luck, that's
not my primary language.
We talk about primary care.
We've given talks about
the trauma informed care
of children with special needs,
something I don't think
we spend as much time
thinking about but just
the trauma that comes
with learning that your
child will have special needs
and most importantly the
trauma that comes with
interfacing with all
the service providers,
because while everybody who's sitting
in this room does the conversation right,
what we know for a fact is that
not everybody out there uses
respectful language when
talking about our kids.
And then as of today we're gonna
be talking about the skin too.
And if you haven't guessed
it from my way of talking,
I'm a pretty excited person
and so when we find a problem,
I have a saying no deficiency,
so we immediately take it up as a project
and there's been a few issues that
we've kind of taken up as important areas.
One is a communication toolkit project,
so developing tools to help families
support their children's
communication development.
A transition toolkit project to develop
Down syndrome specific transition tools
for our teens transitioning to adult care.
A Down syndrome autism
dual diagnosis project
which is actually a
multicenter effort that's both
research based as well
as recommendation based.
And then just a lot of advocacy about ABA,
and as many of you may
know, as of July 1st, 2018,
ABA is now a benefit that's avaialble
to children who don't
have an autism diagnosis
as long as they have Medi-Cal,
and hopefully that will ripple
on to private insurance,
but we don't have providers, right?
The wait time is nine to 12 months
and that's absurd and that's illegal
and that's against our
federal entitlements
and so we've been working
really hard to change this.
Which is why I asked that
question yesterday about
increasing rates for
regional centers for example,
because until we increase
funding for these services
then we're gonna be stuck
with the scarcity of providers
who can't move to the Bay
Area to provide services.
A word about the communication project.
This is the love of my life.
The boy and the communication,
I'm a big talker.
So words certainly help
us verbalize our needs,
our interests, our emotions,
our knowledge about the world,
but it doesn't stop there,
we don't just use words
to talk to each other,
we also use words to think,
to learn, to memorize
for executive function, right?
Today, when I was really
nervous I was like
alright Noemi you gotta chill out,
you gotta chill out, you
can't just freak out.
So right? Behavioral regulation.
You cannot hit your chest like this,
people are looking at you.
So we need words for a lot of things.
And in our children with Down syndrome
verbal communication will be delayed.
I describe it as trying to talk
with a big s'mores marshmallow
in your mouth, right?
Big tongue, small oral
cavity, low tone, real hard.
But the desire to
communicate won't be delayed,
and that's so frustrating, right?
We worry so much about individuals
with locked in syndrome but
how different is wanting to say something
and not having the tools to do it?
And the Regional Center of the East Bay
which is the main regional
center I interact with
will look at language ongoing
through the IFSPs and the
regular evaluations
but won't be able to do
a speech evaluation until
the child is 18 months,
because that's when it's thought that
kids can start really
being delayed for speech,
and so speech therapy
services specifically
won't be put in place at
least until 18 months,
often later because it's
the same issue as ABA,
there aren't enough providers and
that's no fault to the regional center,
they're underfunded,
but it's just the way it is.
And when it comes to speech
therapy through insurance,
the wait time right now
is one to three years,
and that's just wrong.
So we've been working on a
communication collaborative
with a couple of speech
therapists in our area,
Bettina Larroude, who has
worked with individuals
with Down syndrome for more than 20 years
even though she looks like she's 30,
and has done research, she's bilingual.
Susie Schonberg, who works in one of
our local school districts
as a AAC specialist,
augmentative and
alternative communication,
but she's also a speech therapist
and has an invaluable experience.
And then Raquel Ramos,
who's a nurse here at UCSF
and volunteers her time to
us and she's just incredible.
And our vision is based on science,
it's based on evidence
that being exposed to sign
and picture exchange communication system
enhances total communication
and communication efficacy
and also speeds up verbal
language acquisition.
It leads to having longer
sentences and a larger vocabulary,
and as well as regulates behavior.
So our goal is to create
toolkits that we can hand
to families that include
signs in batches, right?
'Cause what I have found is that when I go
and tell families start
learning some sign,
that feels real overwhelming,
go on learn a new language, go ahead,
as you're juggling all the other things.
But if you say learn five signs for me
before the next time we see each other,
and those five signs have been thought of
as the right five signs
for your level right now,
and then when you come back and
you've learned these five signs,
and if you haven't learned that
by the next time, no problem, right?
We'll keep working, we'll keep doing this,
then I'll give you five more signs,
and then I'll give you five more signs.
And then all of a sudden I feel
real efficacious in using sign.
And the love of my life
that I showed you earlier
is the prime example of
someone if once someone
evaluated him just on his verbal language
would appear to be profoundly
profoundly delayed,
but when you take into account his signs,
all of a sudden he's doing much better
than one would have previously thought.
I wanna spend a couple of
minutes on the dual diagnosis of
Down syndrome and autism spectrum,
because it's really common
and it used to be thought
up until the 80s that
kids with Down syndrome
couldn't have autism, right?
They're so friendly.
However, it turns out that Down syndrome
is a genetic risk factor
for having autism,
and rates of autism in
individuals with Down syndrome
are higher than those in
the general population.
At least 10% of individuals with
Down syndrome also have
an autism diagnosis,
some other studies suggest
a much higher incidence.
And it's a challenging diagnosis.
There's diagnostic overshadowing,
are you stimming 'cause
you have Down syndrome
or are you stimming 'cause
you're autistic too?
Are you language delayed because
you have Down syndrome
and we expect it of you?
Or do you also have autism?
Are you really really sick because
you have a G-tube and a trach and all
of these other things are going on?
And that's really obscuring,
obfuscating the developmental picture.
But recognition is imperative
that when you talk to
the Down syndrome autism connection
they'll tell you you've
got to treat the autism
before you start talking about
supporting Down syndrome.
So what is the profile of
someone with the dual diagnosis?
Markedly there's a lack
of joint attention,
and if you know kids with Down syndrome
then you know that they wanna
know what you're up to, right?
What's going on, what's going on?
I wanna be in your business.
And that's missing often in
kids with a dual diagnosis,
but not missing completely, right?
They might come and look
at what you're doing
and then be incredibly happy doing
their own thing for the rest of the time.
And the majority of their
play is more self directed.
I'll be over here
playing my favorite game,
you do your thing, I might
look at you and check you out,
but mostly I'll be doing my thing.
Lack of nonverbal communication,
so that's why I love sign, right?
Because when I am following families
and I ask them what new
words have you learned?
What about new signs,
what about new gestures?
How is your child
indicating this and that?
What often emerges as kids are growing
is that rather than at least pointing,
shrugging, doing all
kinds of Italian gestures,
hand movements to express themselves,
there seems to be less
of a communicative drive.
And it doesn't mean that they
don't want to communicate,
but that's autism in a nutshell, right?
Saying a lot without saying anything,
that's what I'm talking about when
I'm talking about kids with
Down syndrome without autism.
A lot of sensory issues,
and all of our kids can have
sensory issues but they are
really prominent in our
kids with dual diagnosis,
especially around food, clothing, diapers,
textures of terrain.
Some kids are more hypoactive,
some kids are more hyperactive.
They'll look at you in the
eyes for a minute and then
they'll go back to looking
at whatever they're looking,
there's less of that
communicative eye contact,
it's more like are you still there?
Alright, cool. Still there? Okay, cool.
Motor mannerisms, again,
stimming I call it,
the Kardashians of developmental
disabilities, right?
You come home, you don't
wanna think about anything,
so you turn on trash TV and
you just watch it, right?
And how's that different from
rocking or flapping, right?
It's about the same thing.
But if someone would rather do this
than engage in anything
else and they don't do this
just for a minute when they're tired,
but they do it as their
favorite thing to do,
then I start to get more
concerned about a dual diagnosis.
But here's the kicker.
The sociability is often retained,
and that's what I see in a lot
of my kids with a dual diagnosis
is that I walk in the
room and they're like ah!
And they come and hug you and then
they go and do their own thing, right?
And they're still loving
and that thing that the
moms of kids with autism alone
feel they struggle with a lot
more is that lack of
effusive demonstrations
is often retained in our
kids with Down syndrome,
and I think that that's real tricky.
So we look for all of these things
and when we suspect a dual diagnosis
we don't have the staff
to do an ADOS or an AIR
or a social emotional questionnaire
or an aberrant behavior
checklist right in our clinic,
but we do refer out or
recommend an evaluation.
And we focus on the idea
that this doesn't change
anything about who your kid is,
it just informs us on how
to best educate your child.
There's clearly disparities
in access to healthcare
transitions in individuals
with Down syndrome,
as published by this group in 2018.
Individuals with Down
syndrome are less likely
to be encouraged to take ownership
of their own care than other individuals
with special healthcare needs.
And after adjusting for
all kinds of other factors,
adolescents with Down
syndrome had four times
the odd of not meeting the
transition core outcomes.
And especially again not be encouraged to
take responsibility of their own care.
So that's another project of ours
is developing a transition toolkit
that focuses on healthcare transition,
and we want it to be
specific because a lot
of the families that we serve don't speak
English as a first language or are
socioeconomically underserved as well
and it feels really
overwhelming to go and say
go find a doctor who likes individuals
with developmental disabilities,
it feels a lot more empowering to say
call these clinics and
ask for these doctors,
and that's the research
that we're trying to do is
who in our community is good
at doing this kind of work.
Also as a side note,
all those trainings to
medical students, et cetera?
Is to get them really excited about
adult care of individuals
with Down syndrome.
But also other aspects besides healthcare,
like legal decision making,
who can help you get Power of Attorney,
guardianship, limited
conservatorship or conservatorship
if someone really needs
to be fully conserved.
Financial planning,
having a child with a
disability is expensive.
ABLE accounts are finally
available in California,
we tell all our families
about ABLE accounts.
Special needs trusts,
SSI, everybody gets denied
for SSI the first time around,
we encourage families
to appeal and reapply.
We look at the IEP and encourage ITPs.
In California the law says you must
start talking about transition at 16,
but there's nowhere that says that
we cannot start talking about this sooner,
and we encourage families to do so.
Nothing about us without us.
So I told you I'd talk a
little bit more about Annika.
She is employed through
Global Down Syndrome
Foundation Grant and this
is in partnership with the
Down Syndrome Connection of the Bay Area.
Job coaching is provided by Best Buddies.
I always feel like I'm an octopus that's
grabbing people and
bringing them together to me
so that we can do this work together.
I call our clinic strength in numbers
and I hope the warriors
hear this and fund us.
(laughter)
She makes folders for all of our
families with important information.
She's our laminating queen
and has other clerical duties,
and she actually brings
the folders to the families
at the end of the appointments,
and I always comment on
how amazing it is that
inevitably the child
with Down syndrome makes
a beeline to Annika and hugs her and it's
incredible.
And we also build community,
again strength in numbers.
We have had our 3rd annual
holiday party this year,
and we make it bigger every year.
And this could not happen
without the UC Berkeley
volunteers that we work with,
they actually created a Down
syndrome group on campus
and next Thursday on
World Down Syndrome Day
they'll be handing out stickers.
One of my first volunteers
is in the audience today
and it's just so incredible to see
people get inspired about serving
individuals with disabilities,
and they also do a whole lotta work.
We connect families,
I always ask families is it
okay if I connect you with
another family so that
you can give them support?
And all families inevitably say yes,
please please I wanna help.
We're gonna have our
first annual spring fling,
a collaboration with the East
Bay Regional Parks on May 4th.
It's gonna be superhero themed and
there's gonna be incredible things.
And starting in April
we're gonna have monthly
developmental groups in
collaboration with the
Down Syndrome Connection of the Bay Area.
We cannot do this just
by ourselves as doctors.
Formal shout out to the Down Syndrome
Connection of the Bay Area,
stop by their desk if
you have a chance today,
they're outstanding.
The Silicon Valley Down Syndrome Network
'cause we are expanding serving kids all
the way from Fresno to Humboldt,
we also have to expand our
support network relationships.
And they've also been incredible
in supporting our efforts.
If you have a child that you wanna refer,
some referrals comes from birth hospitals,
it's a mixed model of primary care
and consultative services.
So I'm the primary care physician for
about 60 kids with Down syndrome
and then we provide consultative services
so far for about 60 more kids.
So we've grown a lot in
two and a half years.
And because I'm a pediatrician,
PMD, taking consults for
other primary care doctors,
insurances minds are blown and
sometimes we do get a
little bit of pushback
but there's real exciting
movements so that
soon we'll also be in the
genetics department at UCSF
and able to take more patients.
And this is my plea to you.
If you wanna work with
me I wanna work with you.
If you wanna help I want your help,
I never say no to help.
Contact me and we'll take
questions after the next talk,
which is me again.